[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
goo
ああああああ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
[音楽]
おおおおおお
おおーー
me
おっ
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
goo
[音楽]
ううっうぅうううーん
none
[音楽]
[拍手]
goo
[音楽]
ふーん
[拍手]
goo
me
ブーフ
うんん
いいいいいい
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
[音楽]
ムートン
ああああああうん
[音楽]
ああああああ
me
goo
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
re
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
ルアー
[音楽]
[拍手]
me
うううう
ああああああ
[音楽]
goo
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ございます先ほど映像した曲はですねシオンという曲となっております皆さんもあの心
の中にある
懐かしたみたいなのテーマにして書いた曲なんですね
そしてですね
こちらの1000円札この1000冊も僕にとってすごく懐かしい思い出のあるものと
なっております
僕はもともとヒドン前に立ってですね
表現をすることにすごく憧れを持っていたですね
そして高校時代に音楽の歌のオーディションとかを受けてた
そういった背景があってですねちょうど3年前に福岡の橋の上でですね
歌ってみようと決心をしたですね
いざの橋の上に立ってみるとすごく緊張してですね
歌えなかったんですね
30分くらい自分の中で箸で葛藤したんですけれどもやっぱり
とても恥ずかしくて声なんて出なかった
だからですねその代わりなんですけれども
代わりとしてシミとしてやっていたハンドフルートやってみようかなと思ってあの最初
人前で&フレートをその
したのが一番最初人前で演奏したきっかけなんですね
そして
人前で演奏してしてみたんですけれども
2時間ぐらいそしても誰も聞いてくれなかったんですね
今みたいに小切手マイクがあるわけでもないし
音源もないから片耳にイヤフォンを突っ込んで音を聞きながら面相をしてみた
やっぱり外ですし音も響かないということで誰もキー
てくれなかったそんな中2時間 s をしていたらですね
服がボロボロで髪がぐちゃぐちゃのおじいさんがですね
ちょうど僕の50cm 前ぐらいに立って僕の顔をじーっと見つめてきたんですね
この人何なんだろうと思いながらん
少し怖かったんですけれどもしょうがないから気にせず演奏しようかと思ってシュッ
分間ずっと営巣してました
10分間 s 4していたんですけれどもそんな中ずっと微動だにせずですね僕の顔
僕の目だけをじーっとそのおじいさんが見つめてきたんですね
その方おそらくフォームレスの方だと思うんですけれども
ちょうど2曲演奏し終わった直後にですね僕の胸倉をこのシャツをですね
グッと掴んできてですね服の中に手を突っ込まれたんですねこの人大丈夫かなぁとか
すごく怖い経験をしたんですけれどもそのあとやっぱりおじいさんは
一言も僕と会話をせず立ち去って行ったんですね
そして僕がこうやって服を直していたらですね服の中にこのしわくちゃになった千円札
が入っていたんですね
この川薩多分その本降りその方にとってはすごく価値の高いものだと思うんですね
その後無理その方があの
自分なりの思いというかですね気持ちを振り絞って僕に伝えてくれたということでそれ
にすごく感動してですね僕はこのハンドフルートで
やっていこうと a 決心しましたその時に本当の意味で人の価値って仕事とか学歴と
か
a 社会的身分とかそういったものじゃなくてですね
心に高さなんだなと気づかされたんですね
そしてその方が僕にくださったように僕も人にはいいの溢れる
何か与えられる人間になれればなと思ってフェロハンドフルート奏者になろうとそこで
決めてですね
現在3年間活動を続けております
そして
最後に皆さんと一緒につながりたいなと思います
なのでもう1曲だけ皆さんに僕の想いを聞いてほしいなと思いますどうぞよろしくお
願いします
[拍手]
[音楽]
うずら
me
ん
うん
ううっうぅうううぅううぅん le
ああああああああ
ううううううんん
[音楽]
ん
ムーシューグー2
goo
ん
ふぅ
me
内湯
ふうううう
re ほっん
ああああああ
ん
goo 2
me
goo
[音楽]
ああああああ
par
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
hey
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
[音楽]
うん
goo 2
goo
car
大
[音楽]
ああああああ
ムートン
ん
[拍手]